taliban pleads with washington to show
mercy and compassion and release 10
billion dollars in frozen funds when it
ceased control of afghanistan
afghanistan's foreign minister amir khan
mutahi said the funds would help
millions of countries citizens that are
in desperate need he also claimed
afghanistan's new taliban rulers
are committed in principle to education
and jobs for girls and women and mark
departure for their previous time in
power we saw a history of oppression and
human rights abuses mutaki comments are
not the first time he made a plea for
the funds from afghanistan's central
bank to be released however in october
deputy united states treasury secretary
wali adeyamo told the u.s senate
committee that he saw no situation in
which the taliban would be allowed to
access the reserves what's the
likelihood of these guys getting the
reserves never okay all right so that's
good news if they're not going to get
the reserves so even the current
administration is not going to release
this current administration i i honestly
couldn't tell you what a trump
administration would do i i think he is
such
a [ __ ] when it comes to this stuff that
he that he might actually think that he
could get a deal with them and give them
the money thinking that somehow it's
gonna lead to better or whatever
who's who's a [ __ ] trump you think
trump's a bigger [ __ ]
when it comes to foreign policy
absolutely they surrendered the
afghanistan to the taliban the deal they
signed in doha
that's why the commission's so important
you can't just look at one part of
afghanistan you have to look at the
whole narrative and everything changes
after doha the taliban were high-fiving
each other in the room do you get that
they literally high-fived each other
after pompeo signed the deal
because they realized that they had won
the deal that we signed obligated us to
pull all of our contract support from
the afghan military everything we used
to we did all of their maintenance on
their aircraft i have friends of mine
who are afghan army special forces that
are now fighting a resistance in ponchir
and what they told me was that they were
in the middle of a battle when all of a
sudden their air support just
disappeared it just went away there was
no one flying helicopters their
intelligence went down their
communications went down why because all
of the contractors that were actually
providing those services like u.s
contractors that were contracting the
afghan military under the deal we side
with the taliban had to be pulled by
july
there was we signed a surrender
agreement he signed that i don't care
how popular he might be about anything
else when it comes to afghanistan that
man surrendered the country to the
taliban so that so it would be more
accurate in your mind to consider this a
retreat another withdrawal is that i
don't know what you would call no this
wasn't whatever which just happened in
in august is beyond retreat it's a
fiasco that was a collapse
that that was a complete and total
abandonment of a country and that was
why we were trying to warn about we saw
all of this coming and we understood
that the only way you were going to
properly prevent
the chaos that you ended up experiencing
in the waning days of august was if we
had begun this evacuation in the middle
of winter when we controlled every
single airfield in the country when we
still had 2500 troops that the taliban
were afraid of yeah that they wouldn't
engage with right because they
understood that if they escalated
violence it was going to be returned to
a war that they understood that they
were winning at that point look the one
time i ever got to talk to a member of
the taliban was 2008. we had just gotten
into a battle that morning um the
taliban had taken on an afghan police
force that we had been training and
these guys had just gotten back from
like their their training so they were
actually pretty proficient at that point
they hadn't sold off their weapons and
equipment at that point
um
taliban engages this unit
the afghan police end up killing most of
them by the time we're able to get to
the police they've actually executed
they had captured a bunch of these guys
live and they'd shot most of them in the
back of the head all but one guy
so i get this guy
we explain to the afghans that they
can't kill him that he's a he is now a
prisoner of war he has rights and he has
to come with us for questioning because
he's more valuable alive
so i i take this guy over and we're now
waiting for a helicopter to pick him up
and take him away
and i realized i get a chance to talk to
the taliban i've never seen my enemy up
close i finally get a chance to talk to
this guy
so i sit down as close as i am to you
and
i take off my helmet
i he looks at me he's terrified he's in
flex cuffs right
and so i i make the universal symbol of
do you want something to drink and eat
he nods so i have some food and water
brought over and then i take a sip of
the water and i eat a bit of the food to
show him it's not poison he can trust me
and then i make the universal symbol do
you want a cigarette same thing i i
light up a cigarette in my mouth take a
drag show that it's not poison hand it
to him
and then as he's sitting there and he's
smoking a cigarette and he's drinking
water and he's eating some food and he
kind of calms down a little bit i asked
him i said can i ask you a question
when was the last time you had something
to eat today
and he said actually i haven't eaten in
two days
i said really do you understand that my
country's flying in crab legs from
alaska tonight and steak because it's
tuesday and that's how they feed us on
tuesday but you haven't eaten in two
days i said do you know how many bullets
you had on your person when we captured
you
he shook his head no i said i counted
your weapon you had eight bullets in
your weapon eight i have 300 just in
magazines on my chest alone there's
another 20 000 rounds in my truck right
i said do you have an air force no so do
you have artillery well we have some
mortars but i said what happens if you
if i injure you do you have a doctor or
a hospital that comes and gets you goes
no unless we can get back to pakistan we
probably die i said do you understand
then that if you hurt me my government
is going to spare no expense to make
sure i can come back here and kill you i
have an air force brother i got
artillery i got better armament i got
better arms i'm better fed i'm better
equipped why in the hell are you
fighting me because i'm not here for
your women and i'm not here to convert
you away from islam that you've been
told i'm just here to make sure that
your country isn't used to one day
attack mine again and maybe possibly
give your kids a better chance so why
are you fighting me i'm not your enemy
this guy
who had a quranic education meaning he
went to a madrasa and he memorized the
quran as his schooling
sits in front of me
takes a drag on his cigarette points at
my watch and says
you americans have all the watches
we have all the time
this was 2008.
i knew at that moment we were gonna lose
i knew at that moment he understood how
to better articulate their strategy for
victory than we ever were able to in 20
years in afghanistan i challenge you to
find what the definition of the us
government definition of victory in the
war was it does not exist i looked
donald rumsfeld actually said out loud
he had no idea what he was doing there
and he didn't know how to define the
enemy the closest we could get to that
might have been the most honest answer
anybody ever said in government the
closest i ever heard
was it was the absence of al qaeda and
the taliban
well the
in the absence of an ideology once it
embodied in one person you can't defeat
it i want to i want to address something
here because you went through a lot of
different things there and i want to
kind of bring you back a little bit so
number one powerful story it is a
powerful story you have the watches we
have the time absolutely it tells you
who has leverage because it's a story of
patience okay it's outlast we're going
to outlast you and eventually we'll flip
on you and we'll get what we want well
i'll plead you but but this is the point
i want to make to you so number one you
said trump is a what word did you call
him he said he's a sweetheart he's he's
brilliant he's a genius what was the
word used i forgot okay that's the word
you use and you said because he pretty
much gave him a what that we're gonna
you know by july the contracts all this
other stuff the worst deal you're gonna
leave a little bit out though you'll
leave it a little bit out of steel
you sound like the the the part that i'm
gonna push you give you a little bit of
push back here's the following
why is it
that the one thing obama and biden have
in common
everything
bad that happened during their
administration was bush's fault and
trump's fault why is that i don't
understand why why was it with
everything bad thing that happened in
trump's administration was obama's fault
but that's
important for every american president
what you're doing then what you're doing
is you're playing to that so set that
part aside because the agreement if you
look let me finish i'll listen to you
for 10 minutes
the agreement was
yes here's the contract
in july but it was also we leave
properly in may in the right sequence
the biggest challenge with here is
trump's not the president anymore so you
can't say oh it's trump's watch it it's
not on trump's watch they can sit there
and say whatever they want to say about
this guy trump he was this he was that
he was this he's a negotiator he enjoys
it i think he's a guy that gets a kick
out of sitting there and he thinks he
can outsmart some of these guys you
can't outsmart shady people and the
taliban you're not sitting down with
business people this is not like
businessmen and women that you're
dealing with law and order and rules and
guidelines and all these different
regulations that you got to deal with
they don't give a [ __ ] about law and
order you're not dealing with people
that are reasonable like you so i agree
with you on that side you're gonna go
you know the famous line with the reagan
what was famous line with reagan you we
don't negotiate with
terrorists that's a famous line okay
well he did
there's no reason to negotiate there
however
bring it to today
biden has all these people around him
you claim you listen to your generals
you got millie when they went through
that whole thing nobody answered
anything they were afraid to blame biden
they were afraid to take responsibility
because the careers was on it people are
just kind of sitting there saying it was
as if everybody was walking on eggshells
and we learned nothing about what
happened so maybe the july agreement was
a negotiation but i don't put trump as a
dummy because when when people sit there
and try to underestimate this guy would
be in a dummy i don't think anybody
we've had as a president the last 30 40
years has more experience negotiating
with others in any kind of capacity than
this guy does in the area of negotiation
now does he have foreign policy
negotiation experience like some of
these other guys we've had no obama was
a one-term senator how much experience
does the guy have none uh bush lineage
he comes with a lot of experiences one
phone call away from colin a guy that
was a former director of cia you know
what he's going to get from that guy
he's going to get some kind of counsel
and he's been in that life his entire
life he's had drinks food dinner with
some of the most powerful people in the
world so he's a phone call away from
anybody right so i get bush i get senior
because of prescott you know the
grandfather uh i don't even get uh
clinton but clinton maybe a little bit
of experience with governor yeah rhodes
scholar
i get that i give it to him but uh biden
dude 43 years did you hear what he said
in oh wait about leaving afghanistan but
wait a minute do you remember what he
said in oh wait about it i was there
okay i i work he said if we ever leave
we cannot leave equipment behind we
cannot do this do you understand this is
billions of dollars don't you know the
old adage exactly exact opposite thing
don't you know the old saying in
washington show me a foreign policy
issue with george biden's been a part of
and i'll show you with the no the the
line is show me a foreign policy issue
and i'll show you an example in which
joe biden has been wrong like joe biden
in washington has always considered
never underestimate joe biden's ability
to [ __ ] things up barack obama i i was i
i worked for the central intelligence
agency during the obama administration
and the bush administration and i worked
on afghanistan i i specifically was part
of the debate for what's called the
search okay at that time the vice
president biden was the biggest
proponent of something we called ct
light counter terrorism light the idea
was that instead of so stan mcchrystal
wanted this surge of 100 000 troops in
afghanistan and i understood why because
at that point you have to understand at
that point all of the actual like
fighting prowessness in the united
states military is in iraq
let me give you an example in
afghanistan where i was um the taliban
figured out that uh if you could you you
basically could stop our movement if you
blew up our vehicles right and they
figured out how to make more and more
increasingly powerful bombs out of
fertilizer and gasoline and so they we
we joked that they had the radio shack
solution to the war
they could blow up a 1.3 million dollar
vehicle
with about 20 bucks worth of fertilizer
and gasoline right i mean
the the economics of that are just not
sustainable
so
what ended up happening was was we got
orders from our higher headquarters came
down and said we're sick and tired like
for example my unit was the first unit
ever to be issued was called an mrap a
mine resistant ambush protected vehicle
again these cost 1.3 million dollars per
chassis okay per chassis
the entire what's the what what's the
gdp of afghanistan uh i'd have to look
it up i mean i'm sure i'm sure i'm sure
the mrap budget probably was the gdp of
afghanistan but
we were issued four of these in april of
four
as of the first of may three of them
were destroyed the taliban blew three of
them up in five days where's the taliban
getting support from man because
pakistan russia iran
there's no way they're figuring this out
but well actually they were really smart
they had mobile training teams that went
around and experimented on us and
actually figured out that how to like
embed these things underneath the road
they use the road against us they
basically would put these things stacked
up in a v-shape in basically boxes and
then what happens happening is they put
it in a culvert so it's like where a
stream undergoes underneath the road
it's like a tiny little bridge you stack
the box you basically pack the culvert
with explosives and what ends up
happening is the vehicle drives over the
culvert there's an explosion that
happens the explosion isn't what kills
everybody it's the force and it's all
the volume of the road coming up and
then flipping the vehicle that's what
was killing people
so
i tell you all this
um because
it came down from our higher
headquarters about mid-summer 2008 we're
sick and tired of losing vehicles and
people
we have
in that order probably yeah we have
these the these engineering assets that
are called route clearance patrols
they're these big you think the vehicles
we drive are big and expensive theirs
are way bigger and way more expensive
and they're designed specifically to go
out and they they clear the path in
front of you they clear the whole road
of roadside bombs
we had three of these packages for like
three of these route clearance units for
the whole country in 2008. do you
understand how long
missions then back up because you're
waiting for one of these three assets to
be available so what mcchrystal is
saying is i need everything from iraq
there's only so many of these types of
equipment in the u.s military most of
them are currently in iraq i want them
brought to afghanistan in such large
numbers that we can basically go back
out and re-win the afghan war because
what a lot of people don't realize was
that the taliban basically went to
ranger school over 2006 to 2007 and by
2008 had fought us to a standstill and
so mcchrystal comes back and reports all
this and says i need a hundred thousand
troops it's the only way we're going to
turn the tide and obama is weighing the
decision about whether to do this now in
obama's ear is the vice president and
he's saying uh-uh i want that's the
wrong move we need to go a completely
different direction we need to do
something called counter-terrorism light
what we need to do is we need to
actually draw down our footprint we need
to reduce the number of troops in
afghanistan down to about at that point
it was around twenty thousand thirty
thousand he goes we need to get down to
about five to ten they need to be all
special operations in intelligence
troops we shouldn't have a big military
footprint we should be doing targeted
strikes specifically on al qaeda and
taliban leadership and that should be
our only presence and he pushed this
hard and obama chose to go with what we
called the middle option which was not
necessarily the surge
and not counter-terrorism light he
surged by an additional 30 to 40
thousand forces it didn't work like a
politician yeah he had so the this is by
them by the way the reason i'm bringing
elizabeth this has been in the back of
the biden's head since that but this is
what you gotta understand and this is
where i think america needs to
understand this is where our journalism
in this moment is failing us yes because
if we believe the hunter bot in emails
if we believe that he's that the big guy
is getting tens of millions of dollars
from chinese corporations from pakistani
corporations from ukrainian russian
corporations while this is happening
he's advocating against the people who
are fighting our own he's advocating
he's doing business for at the very
least doing business with and for the
very people who are fighting against our
own troops in a proxy war and this guy
is now the president united states of
america i'm not there's no way to make
an allegation about that there's a lot
of you know uh there's a lot of
correlation there you know correlation
isn't causality but it's worth
investigating man seeing okay who
exactly was paying him how much money
how much influence did he have and how
much influence did they have supporting
the enemy of america at that time now i
i now in fairness to anybody listening
my personal bias is i don't think we
should have ever been in afghanistan i
don't think we should have ever been in
iraq i think the patriot act is the
single worst thing that's ever befallen
planet earth from a geopolitical
standpoint so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]